The United States Postal Service is now thinking
about closing post offices around the country
ahead of a presidential election in which
we are anticipating more people than ever
will vote by mail because of this thing called
the global corona virus pandemic, which has
been acutely mishandled by Donald Trump.
Now, we're going to be talking today about
a lot of angles on vote by mail, including
how to vote by mail.
But this is, I think, where it makes sense
to start.
We knew when it looked like vote by mail was
going to be a big deal this November that
the post office was going to be a target.
And part of the reason why is Republicans
love going after the post office even when
there's not a pandemic.
And when people are not particularly planning
to vote by mail.
Trump loves talking about how the post office
is inefficient.
Republicans love talking about privatization.
U.P.S., FedEx, they're better than the post
office.
The post office is kind of a perfect target
for people like Donald Trump and many Republicans
because you can talk about privatizing while
shrinking government while attacking government
inefficiency and saying stuff like if the
post office can't even get it right.
How could we possibly have the government
handle health care?
That's often the way they like to talk about
it.
And then while we were already suspicious
about Trump's plans for the post office, Trump
goes and appoints a huge donor from his campaign
donor to his campaign, rather, Lewis Dejoy
as postmaster general, who immediately starts
talking about reevaluating the post office.
Talking about a fresh look at the post office,
limiting overtime hours for postal workers.
And then we get a clearer picture of what
the plan is.
We've now heard from Democratic Senator Joe
Manchin of West Virginia that he has been
receiving letters that there are plans for
closures of post offices in the state of West
Virginia, which may just be the very beginning
of this strategy.
When Manchin sent a letter to Trump's new
postmaster general to essentially say, what
on earth is going on here, he got some vague
response similar to what we already talked
about.
You know, we need to take a fresh look at
how the post office should be run.
Now, I actually found a document from the
Congressional Research Service called Common
Questions about post office closures.
And it explains how and under what circumstances
post office branches can be closed.
And when you look at this document on page
nine, it says, what is that process?
And the the federal law around closing post
offices includes that there must be adequate
notice of the intention to close or consolidate
branches at least 60 days prior to the proposed
date of the closure.
And if a decision is made to close a post
office, everybody served by that post office
must be notified.
And the post office has to wait at least 60
more days before proceeding with the closure.
Anybody who is served by a post office that
may be closing has the right to appeal the
closure, and there will be up to 120 days
to consider the appeal.
So if you just look at the calendar, it's
already too late to close post offices before
the election.
By the normal process, how can you get around
this?
I'm guessing you understand the way this is
going to go.
Emergency's.
There is something called an emergency suspension
process, but the situations where you can
use such a process to close a post office
branch is very, very limited.
These are limited situations.
For example, if the post office is in a building
that you rent from, you know, a landlord,
a private landlord and the landlord closes
the building as an example, you would be able
to close the post office.
The post office would have no choice in that
case.
But the close sooner than the normal timeline.
But right now, we certainly don't meet that
standard.
And if kids are going back to school, you
can't really argue that it's safe for kids
to be in school, but post offices have to
close.
So here's the plan that they're cooking up.
Cut overtime if carriers can't finish their
daily deliveries without taking overtime.
They have to bring the undelivered mail back
to the post office the next day.
They've got to take out the new mail plus
the leftover stuff from day one.
Can't finish it by 5:00 p.m. Bring it all
back to the post office.
Day three, you now have to deliver that day's
mail, plus the leftovers from day one and
the leftovers from day two.
I think you understand.
That's part of the plan.
And meanwhile, look at whether.
They might be able to shut down some branches
as Donald Trump continues to publicly assail
the ability of the post office to deliver
absentee ballots.
Now, that's the plan.
It doesn't match up with reality.
And the Postal Service has actually said not
Trump's postmaster, but others in the Postal
Service have said, we have that, we've got
this.
We can handle the the ballots.
That's really not a big deal for us.
Donald Trump, however, is going to continue
casting doubt about that.
And that's what we're going to talk about
next.